[MUSIC PLAYING]
Fitness affects us all.
And many times, we do fitness
activities throughout the day
without even being
aware of it, like
when you're walking up
the stairs to your office,
or when you run after your bus,
or when you enthusiastically
play video games during
your coffee break.
The good thing is
that Google Fit
can keep track of all
of these activities
so you get credit for all that
exercise that you're doing.
And here's where you
developers come in,
because all these
activities Google Fit
can keep track of opens up
the opportunity for new apps
to be created-- apps that
have never been seen before.
That's what's called a
window of opportunity.
Let's have a look.
Kicking it off
with martial arts,
you can now record
your fitness activities
while performing martial
arts, like this guy over here.
[KARATE SOUNDS]
But martial arts is only
one of the supported sports
that has a punch to it.
Boxing is another classical one,
like what this guy is doing.
[PUNCHING NOISES]
[BELL]
But there is so much more
you can do with Google Fit.
Dancing, for example,
has another punch to it,
like you can see over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
But Google Fit is not
limited to that either.
It supports all of
the classical sports--
for example, American football
that you can see here.
[GROANING]
We'll save the details
for the studio.
So as you see, there are
many different activities
in Google Fit, and we have
only touched on a few of them.
There are lots more, like
playing tennis, or golf,
or doing jumproping, or
playing hockey, or meditation,
aerobics, rock
climbing, kayaking,
or even Zumba dancing.
Google Fit supports over
100 different activities.
So what are you waiting for?
Get your coding engine
started, and go out there
and create that next viral
app using Google Fit.
[MUSIC PLAYING]